God, Nathan,
you're gorgeous.
She's got a banging,
banging, banging body.
Um, it's hard
not to look at.
The things I would do
to that man.
Oh, I don't even
want to say that.
I know what I'm gonna
be doing after this party.
I don't know
if I'm gonna be able
to keep my hands off of him.
We're really trying
to be good for Lana,
but there's a lot of sexual
tension between us.
Lana, what are you
doing to me?
There's a good 99.99999%
I'm breaking
a couple of rules tonight.
I really want to kiss you
right now.
I'm in trouble.
You pushed him away
6 seconds too late, missy.
I kissed Holly…
That five-a-day
is not recommended.
OK, I feel like this is
one of the first times
in a long time that I'm like
open to, like, love.
Yeah, I can see
how much you like him.
The date really
made me realise
how much
I really fancy Holly.
She's everything
a guy wants to see
before and after bed.
Holly is top of the list.
Uh, not many good ideas
start with removing
your shorts.
Things did get a bit hot
and steamy last night,
a bit of touching,
but, to be fair,
I don't think
we broke a rule last night.
Like, I'm a smart guy.
I always find loopholes.
Smooching through fabric,
I've got no material
for this.
We cannot be responsible
for losing any more money.
That's gonna be
a little bit tough.
Hey!
This is, like, probably
one of the hardest things
that I've ever had to do.
No!
I'm seeing handcuffs,
I'm seeing rose petals,
I'm seeing the big bath.
I mean, it's like you almost
want a brother to fail.
Whoa! It's hot.
Maybe you're right to be
a little bit worried.
Lana, what are
you doing to me?
And you want me to be good?
The last few days
have just shown me that
I'm so much more
emotionally invested here
than I really thought
that I was going to be.
The man is beautiful.
Obviously hard to keep
my hands off of him.
But I just want to make sure
that I'm approaching this
the right way because I…
I really, really, really
like Nathan.
I really wanted to take
my time with you now
and, like, prove to us
and prove to everyone
that, you know, we actually
really do like each other.
We're in the hot water
right now.
I think everyone's
gonna be fuming.
-We hit a couple home runs.
-What?
Definitely got to know
the stadium.
I'm feeling like Nathan
and I are now antagonists.
And I just…
It hurts me to think that.
Because of Holly
and Nathan's
numerous rule breaks
last night,
your prize fund is now at…
zero dollars.
Oh, damn!
Shit.
What?
As a couple, you have
broken the most rules,
but one of you has shown
more disregard for the rules
than the other,
and that person
will be going home.
The guest leaving
the retreat…
is…
Nathan.
It's a real sad moment
for me.
I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry.
I have detected
for the first time
regret on your part.
And therefore…
your journey
may not be over.
What?
I feel like I'm losing
a part of me.
It feels like a break-up.
Obviously, I thought I would
have more time with him.
Just goes to show that
you need to really cherish
every day
because you never know
when is the last time
you're gonna see someone.
This workshop
is super intense,
but I just want
to keep growing.
I'm gonna keep
trying my best.
I think from this workshop,
I've probably learned more
than I have
in the past few weeks.
Brenden's enabled me
to actually understand
other ways to find
connections and love.
I believe…
that you have discovered…
genuine feelings for Holly.
Therefore…
your time in the retreat…
is not over.
I'm back, baby!
Oh, my God!
I think this is one of
the happiest moments
in my entire life.
Oh God, and he looks
so good in all black.
That one-on-one workshop
really flipped a couple
of switches in my heart.
It's definitely changed
my perception
on the way I see Holly.
I've never felt
this way before,
but normally
when I get these feelings,
I just run away because
I'm scared of commitment.
I've never met
a man like Nathan.
I love him to death.
I just really hope
that he feels the same way.
You know, now's the point
where I can tell you…
It would be wrong of me
not to say this…
I genuinely do love you.
I want you to know
that I love you too.
I can't believe
I came in this retreat
and fell in love.
It's been so long
since someone
has said to me
that they love me.
And, yeah, I'm just…
I'm the happiest girl
in the world.
It's been
an emotional journey
and I just couldn't be
happier right now.
Oh my…
Lana's treating us.
Thank you, Lana.
Nathan and I finally got
a green light.
Um, that was a special kiss.
Best day ever, best date
in the retreat by far.